why are they trying to suppress
information why are they trying to make
you think that all of us are bigots and
racists why do they want you to think
we're all mean scary people well it's
all a giant distraction
you know it i know it they know it they
know that we know it and they keep doing
it uh here is nbc's yamiche alcindor uh
saying that the democrats do have to
shift away have to shift the narrative
because uh they're doing a pretty pretty
shitty job about everything you know has
to
tell people why this is so important
well it's a poignant tweet from liz
cheney who has really weathered so much
backlash within her party to take this
stance but she's saying that this is
about democracy this is about the
american experiment and whether or not
we want our democracy to fall apart or
whether or not we want to look at what
happened on january 6 and be cautioned
by it and learned from it
and really understand what happened i
think the biggest challenge for
lawmakers here as they talk about these
sort of huge ideas of american democracy
and sort of the experiment that we're
all living and benefiting from possibly
being brought to his knees is whether or
not they can make people care andrea
there are so many things that people are
juggling between gas prices and
inflation baby formula abortion
and
the shootings that are happening
these lawmakers are going to try to now
have a narrative to focus the country's
attention to say look at this thing do
not turn away and understand that while
all those other things are really really
important the foundation of our country
what makes our country function is a
democracy that we have to protect and
they're gonna have to do that in the
face of republicans who are lying still
about the 2020 election and who are
getting elected and installing people
who have um the really motivations that
were that were what happened and why
people broke into the capital in the
first place
okay so what's interesting about that
again i know the people that broke into
the capital we better focus on that and
okay blah blah blah but she sort of
acknowledges that the democrats are not
doing well and we all know it and again
you don't need me to read you the polls
on these things just check the price of
gas and everything else but it's not
just that the democrats you're doing are
not doing well it's that nobody is
tuning into these ridiculous shows
anymore and that's why they constantly
have to ramp up the hysteria the ratings
are absolutely abysmal we've got some
info from fox news despite a busy news
month during may that included tragic
mass shootings and major political
primaries msnbc was outdrawn during may
by such networks as fx bravo paramount
tv land
espn2 freeform lifetime and hallmark
among the prime time demo
now i haven't had cable in a while but
you know golden girls used to be on tv
land it used to be on hallmark and it
used to be on lifetime i don't know if
it's still on any of those channels but
this if this is all just that the golden
girls is crushing msnbc then i'm gonna
pop open a bottle of champagne at the
end of today because obviously you could
learn far more from four retired women
trying to live a good life
in miami in the mid 80s into the early
90s than you could from anything on
msnbc but do you see the point so what's
happening is people are tuning out of
that crap despite all of the craziness
right we have all this craziness related
to abortion and roe v wade the shootings
all of the stuff that's going on with
the economy
and people are just tuning out of their
nonsense